[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
alors là tu m'a foutu un coup dans la
gueule
ah bon avant de tarifs je me trouvais
beau gosse est bien attendu et là je me
trouve dégueulasse
justement vous ranger leurs ondes depuis
tout à l'heure pour fêter les deux
millions d'entrées en est apparue tous
les deux si tu faisais plus de 2
millions d'entrées
tu mettais le slip de patrick chirac que
j'ai intitulé le seul et de papé qui
rate toujours j'ai sur moi maintenant
non mais c'est le pc le 13 mai à temps
et quoi que tu peux tu va l'enlever
bah oui je vais l'enlever
[Applaudissements]
durée toi qu'est ce que vous pensez du
transport en commun en transports en
commun parisiens
ouais que du bien du bien et votre frère
elle en pense quoi va le faire vous êtes
déjà ramené mon frère malo
[Applaudissements]
39e nancy montreuil
merci surtout
on sera forts et la fin de la chronique
de ken hill vas-y vous avez rien dessous
non mais laisse le singe et bien des
souvenirs si j'ai quelque chose pour ce
que tu vas voir
[Applaudissements]
on continue à l'ailé chérie je peux pas
aller là dessus je vois rien là c'est
trop loin à l'arrière
hier matin a eu un gars je devais dormir
chez un jour me sexy mats et qui jouit
aux matches et aux mères mais si on me
met pas mathieu jean michel aulas l'idée
était de faire une parodie viennent chez
nous mais je ne vous cache pas que
c'était pas bienvenue au conte florent
donc on a préféré garder les scènes
coupées les jacquot c'est gratuit bien
je fais ce qu'ils regardent plus est les
à-côtés la photo malling déjà bâti
mathieu ne va pas lui déjà mathieu a
voulu faire une vidéo sap chatte avec le
chien de jambi problème assez rare
le chien ne veut pas apparaître sur les
réseaux de maths qui n'a plus rien à
dire on regarde mais moi j'ai rien
compris je ne vous la vérité tout ici
est ce que tu es déjà sortie est
quelqu'un de connu mouais aller bébé non
non non pas moi hanouna 1
allez tu le saurais j'aurais appelé tout
de suite tu allais à moi apam en garde
pas je sais que si tu es morte pour
pâques
daniel éteint la télé à la merci franck
dumas est venu nous voir parce qu'il a
tenu sa promesse il nous avait dit qu'à
plus de 2 millions d'entrées pour son
film y reviendrez nous voir merci mon
froc
on est tellement heureux pour toi le sud
est est fabuleux et je pense que je te
dis je pense comme en délit je me
retrouvais être son assistant pas en 48
mois ce que nous ferons oui oui c'est
vrai bref instant je le respecte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]